this is the biggest bartending
competition in the country one of us is
gonna go on so with the whole page it's
definitely a much unique drink of the
night just like it's a dream come true
we have the list we need absolute
silence Carly
Donovan's I was definitely a little bit
let down that I didn't make the tops
head I'm still proud that I was able to
get that far congratulations on making
it to the final ten so you guys are
going to have to create a new drink
tonight you can have to make enough for
four judges and 450 seems so as far as
my performance I did as I did the show
on the road here three two
going overtime can absolutely be the
reason that I could possibly not win
today that was it that was the moment
where everything we go with the bombe
first all the logistics are running
through your mind in split seconds and I
just realized I'm looking for nice right
we have the Boucher but the cocktail
came out great so that's that's a
positive so I'm super nervous ready to
find out the winner no idea how things
are gonna shake out so we'll just have
to wait the emcee comes on the mic says
hey it's time to announce the winners
and then the nerves came back all
anxious anxiety just tell us you won
tell us who won already tell us who
wants a weekend like so we can just
relax
oh man I'm in the running yeah I'm in
the running but there's it's stiff just
based on presentation based on the
judges response time spent with the
drinks it's probably between myself
Julio and Cristian we've got a third a
second in the first place
correct right all right so Gary why
don't you let us know who is third place
in this competition so third place we
have Frank Fontaine from Philadelphia
what up Frank
[Music]
Frank did a great job today
congratulations
my goal is to win this competition I'm I
came here prepared to win the most
imaginative bartenders if I win
having that title is a huge deal it
immediately opens the door for me to be
able to do whatever I want with my
career and bartending and open more
doors for my career in art Nick here we
go in second
mr. Christian Sanders from New York New
York
second place what I might well done
right thank you sir thank you for being
here just sitting there super pumped
my friend had his arms wrapped around me
Scranton was pacing back and forth
people forgot this it's in the back mr.
Hayward please will you announce the
2013 most imaginative bartender
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I knew he was gonna win before I saw him
and then I saw him and I was like yeah
every single movement he made was the
best move you can make in the
competition period period it was amazing
to watch his performance was flawless
literally flawless no mistakes as a
professional he knows exactly what he's
doing his greens was perfect
he knocked it out of the park
[Music]
I represented all the ladies who wanted
to do well in this competition who
wanted to make it to the top 10 I feel
good like I'm not sad I'm not
disappointed like I feel really good I'm
super proud of myself
only Oh congratulations man
congratulations not off I think some of
the best cocktails won no hard feelings
I had a great time it was an amazing
learning experience I have definitely
learned some things from this
competition bartending wise I've seen
some great people make some great drinks
so yeah I'm gonna be a definite better
bartender after this night I feel great
about the competition I had so much fun
I was able to meet so many people and
just get like great exposure and I'm
just super happy to be here and be a
part of everything oh man this like the
entire competition has been it's been
fun it's been eye-opening it's been a
learning experience it's just been a
blast
I really hope to be back here next year
I absolutely am gonna compete and now I
have a year to practice not spilling any
drops out of my jiggers I was surrounded
by 50 of the best bartenders in this
country and what I learned what I saw
like it's gonna change my life next year
I'm going for it for real yeah whatever
happens I'm definitely going for it
again next year I'm only gonna get
better and coming for you who is I'm
next a year from now
upload this competition and I'm Julio
Cabrera from Miami Florida
I started bartending 25 years ago is uh
it was a family tradition
I started bartending without knowing
that it's gonna be like my passion I
found everything I need to be happy
behind the bar I can create and make
jokes and sing behind the bar so it's
like a entertainment and and I love it
also I love to take care of people you
don't make friends and the bar give me
all that to win this competition means
to me a lot as a professional it's a lot
of years behind the bar but I think is
this one of the most important
competition I've ever been
it's huge all the possibility is it's a
brand new life this is another another
step in your in your working life so
it's it means a lot
[Music]